please remember that it's cool when we
do
it it's a problem when y'all do it hello
hello yo
yo hello
hello yes yes yes yes
yes so Abu Hera's mother's name is um
bin brother this isn't about Abu hrera
this is about what is the okay what is
the let's go to the question what's the
yes what's the why are you asking the
question what is the inil because I want
to know because you guys say that we
don't have it and no it doesn't exist
I'm getting different answers on
it yes so even after we tell you the
evidence you still don't want to know
what do you mean I still don't want to
know after you tell me the evidence now
then I'll know your position is not to
know what the angel is you don't want to
know what are you here to tell me are
you here to tell me that I don't want to
know or are you going to answer
no because I've heard this many times
you don't want to know so you so so you
don't know what the angil is is what I'm
gathering I do know what theil is Allah
has told us in the Quran what theil is
okay good tell me what is
it you already know what the angel is so
what is it then how about okay how about
this let's say it together already know
why okay okay okay okay hear I hear you
I hear you hear you you already
know I I have a way I have a way for us
to do this I have a way for us to do
this shut your stupid P let's let's see
if we could get this together on the
count of three I'm gonna unmute you on
the count of three let's say what the
inil is
together okay since we both know what it
is let's say it together okay
one
2 3 Matthew Mark L
John you didn't say it with
me all right let's try it again one
let's say it
together Matthew
J why are we saying different things I
thought we both know both knew what it
was so who's wrong and who's right then
that's the
question so your position do you want to
know what the inil is so if I tell you I
knew from my atheist point of view who
said I'm a
Muslim do I want to tell you from
atheist view are you are you a Muslim or
not I am a Muslim alhamdulillah I am a
Muslim so stop wasting my time dude
what's the
in the injil is a law the Torah is a law
is a Commandment that was sent to the
prophet okay
Isa is the of the Torah this is what the
is the in of the Torah the is not the
Torah oh what's the difference is
separate from the Torah what the differ
these are laws the Shar laws when a
prophet came with a law it was given in
a book such as the tablet can you give
me an example of I got you can you give
me an example of this what I'm trying to
tell you can you give me an example
hello hello yes can you give me an
example of this law that's in the Ino
like can you give me an example what's
one of the laws that's in
Theo we don't need to follow the in we
don't need to know I didn't ask you we
follow the Quran I just asked for an
example of Allah in the does not exist
anymore so how can I tell you something
oh it doesn't exist how do you know it
doesn't exist how do you know that
because the Quran is the final word but
the Quran say but the Quran the Quran
says the inil existed the Quran says it
exists this is logic when the command
changed when the Lord get off my panel
thanks for coming get out of here you're
idiot get out of here thanks for coming
man straight robot mode man you do you
do you guys think that this looks good
that this shows that your religion has
answers that your religion can actually
stand up to
scrutiny you guys could just turn into
robots we believe that the we believe
that it doesn't exist anymore if we
believe theil we believe theil is a law
given to Jesus Isa
the the we believe is a revelation from
Allah it's revelation we don't need the
we follow the
Quran is the Revelation
from we don't need the we follow Prophet
Muhammad we need the the is not here the
doesn't exist anymore you don't know
what the you don't want to know
the
bro are we
serious am I talking to human being
really can I please speak to a human
[Laughter]
being I just want to speak to a human
being big
dog okay let's see who else we got M I'm
letting new people up man we've already
spoken on this subject many a time I got
to let new people come and try it I love
you I gota let people new people try
man he said but they're all
acoustic how you doing man I'm fine I'm
fine alhamdulillah how are you doing I'm
pretty good all hallelujah praise be to
the Lord
Jesus alhamdulillah yeah hulah means
alhamdulillah yeah it's Aramaic language
also it's Hebrew means it's similar it's
very it's similar it's similar
Hallelujah means praise Yahweh
yeah yeah praise God it's it's about
every day to praise God it's before
eating before sleeping wake up the whole
day is um is about to praise God
praising God that's right he loves you
he give you the present and you must
give it something back you know it's not
for free I think uh when somebody give
you a present uh and God loves you I
think he loves people who follows him
yes or not or follow his commandment yes
or not God love sure yeah and what do
what do you think the angel is my
friend well I I think some FES is
confirmed with the Quran some Fus I
think this is from the inil I can
confirm it and some FES like like John
17 ver3 brother it's it's very clear
this verse is very clear and this is
what we are telling you that the father
is the the the God is is is the is he's
the God the Father you know I got you so
Allah Allah is the
Father Allah is the father in your
meaning the father is God no not my no
not my meaning you said according to
this verse for your understanding yeah
that's it's not my understanding is is
Muslim I am Muslim brother but for you
so is this a truth is this a truth about
Allah is Allah the father yeah I speak
in your language no no no not my
language it's it's either like okay for
example let's say I believed in in Idol
would you would you then call Allah an
idol to speak my language no no no right
okay so that's what I'm saying is Allah
is Allah the
father but okay okay okay I'm asking you
when when we say the father and for your
understanding the father who is the
father God or not he's the only true God
the Father yeah so is that Allah is
Allah is Allah the father we confirm we
confirm yes okay I'm I'm with you yes
it's he's the father when he say he's
the only true he's the father I'm
confirmed with you absolutely so all
right so just to be clear Allah is the
father who is Allah is is in your
language the father no no no stop say
stop saying my language stop doing that
because again if my language was that
Allah the ID or God the idol is the only
true God you wouldn't start calling God
an idol to match my language so let's be
clear we're not talking about my
language we're talking about whether or
not this is a true characteristic or
true quality or identity of of Allah is
Allah the father is he regardless of if
I use that language or not is he the
father yes he is the father thank you
all right cool so Allah is the father
and and Jesus is his son then he is the
son yes and and
we we we deny the Trinity brother
because we we find in the in also in the
Bible that in many verses also Jesus was
sending yeah sending to the lost sheep
of Israel he's he was sending God's
message it's one message it's it's easy
message to understand just for his
creation there is only one God it's why
it's so difficult I think I see I see
it's not difficult I see so okay so
Allah is the Father and Jesus is his son
and this isn't difficult this is
actually quite simple you're saying so
when the Quran says that Jesus is not
Allah's son and that Allah is not a
father but he's only your
master why are you contradicting what
the Quran
says I'm not Contra I'm just just I tell
you for your understanding the one and
only the father is for me God this is
also my understanding I'm confirmed with
you now brother you said yes Allah is
the father you said yes Jesus is his son
but the Quran says he's not a son but I
just asking you yeah who is the father
for you you said to me he's the one and
only the Creator the you know no no no
no I didn't say that who's the father so
just to be clear why are you
contradicting the Quran when it says
Jesus is not Allah's son
why are you saying Jesus is Allah's
son I'm not saying he son he you did you
said yes no when we we we we just talked
about the Father the the meaning of the
father yeah do you do you want do you
want to say it again let me ask you
again brother
just it looks like it looks like we're
going back and forth let's let's get
some clarity okay let's get some
clarity is Jesus Allah's son yes or no
please no earlier you said he was you
said yes he is his son so which one is
it I just talk to you that I am speaking
to your language yeah that's your
language that you understand me yeah
that's all thanks for coming when I say
father Woo You Muslims are a trip today
He Man y'all are a tripped UN today I
love it though keep it coming I ain't
going to lie brother I just came over
here to say one thing is to the
Muslims are you are you a Muslim no sir
I am a Christian okay so I'm only
bringing up M Muslims man come on come
on guys I love you all only Muslims okay
if you have something to say say it in
the comment section love you all but
respect the respect the Live come on
guys let's
see what's up how are you doing pretty
good how are
you I'm pretty good I got to be honest
I'm not a Muslim I'm looking my way into
religion so I'm going to be honest with
you
straightforward um so what what is the
yeah I believe it's the gospels uh for
sure yes so this is this is for the most
to answer if you're not a Muslim then
this isn't for you my friend this isn't
for you I'm going to respect your time
have a good one thank you thank
you let me just take a let me just take
a break and read some super chats